- I'm one of the most
popular entrepreneurs
in our current society, no question.
I'm like super proud
of that accomplishment,
I also find it intriguing
that I'm probably the one
that talks most about the
shortcomings of entrepreneurship,
and how many fake entrepreneurs there are.
I'm not getting high on my own supply.
(upbeat music)
Kickstarter works when
your fucking idea is bomb,
when you know how to write copy,
when the pictures and videos are on point,
when you get a whole bunch of people
that build awareness for it,
and it's, you know,
everything is execution.
What do I think about it? It
works, for 1% of the people.
It's the same thing I think
about entrepreneurship,
it's the same thing I think about
design and rap and fucking life.
What do I think about cooking?
Good idea for Julia Childs.
First of all, lemme give
you a good piece of advice.
I don't how, I don't care
if it's a thousand dollars,
spend 25 to 50 cents on the dollar,
on whatever the fuck you're up to,
if it works then spend the other 50.
I get emails that are heartbreaking,
fucking worked my fucking
face off for 13 years,
sold my doughnut shop, had
130,000, started an app,
bought cryptocurrency, fucking
tried to be an influencer,
and I'm ass out.
In seven months I fucking assed
out everything I worked for,
you know, be smart.
Just keep making money,
you know what I mean.
You can get caught up in
like I'm gonna invest money,
it sounds good,
until it's gone.
(knocking)
- [Man] Thank you so much.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
- [Woman] Nice meeting you.
- Such a pleasure, nice to meet you.
(upbeat music)
Stick to your DNA instead
of what looks good.
People get seduced by things,
and I don't know if that's
happening to you or not.
But like the idea of like
building a 100 million dollar app
is like in everybody's fucking mind.
- We switched, we had been
on Vendor Central, which is--
- I know about it.
- very good to get noticed,
because Amazon controls it.
They're just buying directly from you
and we switched to a third-party seller
now that's proprietary--
- RPL
You have to become, no joke,
disproportionally educated on Amazon.
To me it's Amazon and Facebook,
more so than Google and Apple,
from an innovation standpoint.
I think they have a better
pulse of the end consumer
and the wants and needs
of that end consumer.
I respect execution too much
and I think that only being a speaker,
only being an author, only being a pundit,
is pontificating and not doing
and I love to pontificate
as my extra curricular
activity to my actual doing.
I'm also even more excited
that my pontifications come
from the outputs of my doing.
Very simply, I think it is
a lot better to take advice
from someone who's done the thing
they're fucking talking about.
You have to understand, I'm
a pure bread entrepreneur,
for real, for real, like documented,
lemonade stands, baseball
carts, DNF student,
long before this
entrepreneurship thing was cool,
like I was on it, it
was me, it's who I was
and I lived the first 20 years of my life
scrutinized by adults
outside of my mom and dad,
who said I wasn't good and
I wasn't gonna make it.
Instead of entitlement I
was brought up in adversity,
which became my strength, I was told
that I lost from the get
by every adult outside of my parents,
so imagine how easy it is
for me to deal with adversity
and negativity and trolling
and set backs and pressure.
It's the fucking dirt that I come from.
Vayner Media is now in year nine,
I've only really run it for seven years.
I've always thought about it long-term
and now it's 900 people
and now it's hundreds of
millions of dollars in revenue
and now it's a big thing,
but a lot of people
that started companies in
2009 through 11 with me,
my homes from Silicon Valley
and others, even though
they raised millions and
millions and millions of dollars,
their companies are out of business now.
(upbeat music)
Hi team.
First of all thank you
so much for being here.
Like 9:53pm on a Tuesday.
This shit makes me fucking happy.
Alright, why don't we go around
and just tell me anything
even if don't like stress
that it might be mundane
or you're new or like whatever,
like what's on your
mind, what's interesting.
- [Employee] I'm excited
about Linkedin in general
for rebranding you as not
Gary V but more like a--
- Gary Vaynerchuk the
CEO, I totally agree,
as a matter of fact AskGaryVee Show,
let's like build on this,
let's start getting
very serious about this,
I think Ask Gary V Show
for the rest of the year
should be the former CEO of Home Depot.
You should have seen in today's,
you weren't in though right, no.
You were watching, you saw what I did
with today's interview?
I made three LinkedIn articles, right?
And I did one about
why reviews are broken.
Your quick hot takes on reviews.
- So hot takes is honestly
I didn't do what's called
360 reviews, because I think they're--
- They're horseshit.
- They're bullshit, yeah.
- They're bullshit, because
they are no different
that you were just saying before.
- [Employee] That was the
one I was talking about
where I could see that he
was already on your rhythm,
now let's really make sure
that this is the video.
- On that note, let's whoever
is in, Justin, take this lead,
let's go through my CRM, you know,
there's inevitably six
real business people
in the Instagram VIP, like,
let's start booking some
guests for AskGaryVee.
- [Man] We have two in the hopper.
- Former like CEO of Home Depot, good.
Let's sit here as long as we can,
so we can see how hot we can get.
(laughs)
Does anybody need anything from me?
- [Employee] Do you think
your podcast content
has been weaker for last seven weeks?
- [Employees] Yes.
- Why?
- [Employee] We just haven't done shit.
- I've been busy.
I also think that we are
remarkably not creative,
for example how the fuck in that world,
are we not doing a
Throwback Thursday episode,
since I've put out content
my whole fucking life,
somebody here, fucking fresh-faced interns
coming out of my ass in here,
why can't one of them watch
Tuesday June 7th 2007s wine show,
where for the first 10 minutes,
I talked about things besides wine
and maybe I made a proper
prediction about Facebook
and that's an actual episode
in the podcast, we could.
The one thing that I would say is,
I think, the same as Andrew was saying,
as a net score we're dominant
and then there's inefficiencies,
there's procedural inefficiencies
and then I think there are unbelievable,
like I don't even want to tell you,
how I judge your creativity
because you play within a
box that you were given,
which makes no sense because
it's the perceived box
you've created for yourself.
I think we would be
more creative, I think.
What?
Great.
I'm glad you love it.
But I think we need to
figure this the fuck out.
We should be the dominant
Throwback Thursday
organization in culture.
And we don't do anything,
I've given you fuckin'
13 years of content.
Use that audio for the
Throwback Thursday episode
that we put up on podcast
this Thursday, there you go.
Enjoy everybody on the
podcast, use that audio.
(soft music)